[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام اذا نواصل من
العربيه تغطيتنا لتداعيات زلزال تركيا
والانعكاسات هذا الزلزال والهزات
الارتداديه بالاخص في سوريا والدول
المجاوره كذلك احدث ارقام القتلى هي عند
الف وستمائه وواحد وخمسين قتيلا في تركيا
اضافه الى
1383 قتيلا في سوريا لكن الارقام لن تكون
ذات معنى مع دوران عجله رفح لانقاذ باقصى
وسييرتها فحتى الان تشترك تركيا وسوريا في
المعاناه من اثار عاصفه ثلجيه عرقله
عمليات الاغاثه بينما تشكو سوريا وحدها من
غياب الامن والبل ومن غياب مفهوم الدوله
في عدد من المناطق ليبقى الرهان في
البلدين على المساعدات الدوليه فنيه كانت
او انسانيه لتجاوز الازمه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
وجع قلبي
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهد مؤلمه نتيجه هذا الزلزال
المدمر الذي وصلت شدته الى 7.8 درجه على
مقياس رختر ثم تبعه ايضا هز ارضيه قويه
وسط توقعات بان تزيد اعداد الضحايا
والمفقودين حول هذا الموضوع والعديد من
النقاط الاخرى انضم الينا من اسطنبول
الكاتب الصحفي فراس رضوان اوغلو وايضا من
بيروت مراسلات العربيه ناهد يوسف اهلا
بكما ابدا معك في ما جديد التحديثات حول
هذه الكارثه من الجانب التركي اتحدث عن
اعداد الضحايا وايضا عمليات الانقاذ انقاذ
المفقودين
نعم يعني ربما الحصيله الاخيره حتى الان
وفق الارقام المذكوره على
شاشتكم الكريمه
1651 القتيل وعدد الضحايا ايضا
يزداد كل فتره يعني ربما الاعلان الاخير
حتى للدول التي
اتصلت واعزت في تركيا من اليونان والصين
واسرائيل والمانيا وروسيا
ودول اخرى اظن ايضا الخبر الاخير الذي جاء
من خطوط الجويه التركيه التي اعلنت فيه
بان هناك رحلات جويه الى ديار بكر واضنه
واليزار دون توقف لم تحدد حتى المده الى
كم يوم بسبب
الاستمرار النقل الى هناك بجميع اشكاله
يعني مساعدات الغذاء الى اخره في في هذا
في تلك الوقت حتى قبل قليل كانوا
زياره 140
سد الموجودين في تلك المناطق المناطق التي
يعني ضربها الزلزال تقريبا كلها
جيده فقط قيل عن 34 سنتا هما ربما لم
يتاثر لكن هناك بعض الروتوش اظن في في تلك
السدود حتى قبل فتره تقريبا ايضا سيد
حزب الشعب الجمهوري والنائب الرئيس التركي
فؤكتاي قام بزياره مشتركه الى الافاد طبعا
هذا للتضامن السياسي داخل
التركياف المعارضه بغض النظر عن الاتجاهات
السياسيه وزير دفاع تركيا ايضا قال قبل
قليل ان السفن الحربيه تشارك في اجراء
متضررين زلزال من انطاكيا الى مرسين وان
القوات الخاصه تشارك في اغاثه ضحايا
الزلزال من المعروف راويه واستاذ فراس
وناهد ايضا مشاهدينا الكرام كذلك بانه
متوسط الز التي تتجاوز قوتها سبع درجات
بلغت اقل من 20
زلزالا على مر التاريخ من هنا مدى وحجم
خطوره هذا الزلزال والتداعيات القاسيه
والمؤلمه المتوقعه له
وهذا زلزال احدث كل هذه الماسي في بعض
المناطق والكثير من الرعب في مناطق اخرى
دون وقوع يعني
ضحايا الحمد لله على الاقل في مناطق معينه
ومنها لبنان ولكن مع اللبنانيين الذين لا
يزالون خائفين
ناهد من حدوث هزات ارتداديه قد تكون قويه
اليس كذلك
نعم طاهر ولهذه الغايه يعني هناك عدد من
المواطنين
نهد
يبدو انه فقدنا نهد يوسف بالصوت على الاقل
وقد نعود اليها في سياق هذه التغطيه
واتابع مع فراس رضوان اوغلو الصحفي من
اسطنبول اهلا بك مجددا الاستاذ فراس الوقت
يعني وقت ماساه والكل متضامن
ومتعارض
لانقاذ من يمكن انقاذه وما يمكن انقاذه
الى اي مدى مع مرور الساعات تتضاءل الامال
في تركيا الرسميه وعند تركيا الشعبيه كذلك
في انقاذ من يمكن انقاذه الحديث الان عن
الاف ربما عشرات الالاف من القتلى في
المناطق المنكوبه عموما
نعم يعني الحقيقه الان الامل ما زال يعني
متواجدا عند الكثيرين لان يعني حتى الان
لم ينقضي لنقل اثني عشر ساعه على الزلزال
قبل قليل كان هناك صدر عن وزاره الدفاع
بعض الجنود التي تفضلت به القوات مضى 24
ساعه
حتى نصف هذا الوقت يعني حتى الصباح تقريبا
عفوا نعم اللي وقبل قليل كانت وزاره
الدفاع انقاذ عده اطفال حتى يعني الجنود
الالقاذ العسكري لنقول ليس المدني استطاع
ان ينقذ بعض
الاطفال في هناك صور لهم حتى قبل قليل كما
نشر خبر فتاه في عمرها السادس عشر تم
انتشالها يعني بخير نوعا ما من تحت
الالقاب اظن ان مازال الامل متواجدا في في
هذه كلما كانت هبه المساعدات الدوليه ايضا
كبيره كلما زاد الامل في ذلك وكلما ساهمت
عوامل اخرى ايضا مثل عوامل الطقس ومثلا
الليل الان يؤثر في عمليات الانقاذ وكذلك
الطقس شديد البروده والثلوج والامطار وذلك
عرقل وصول هيئات الاغاثه الى العديد من
المناطق ولكن انضمت الينا من جديد
مراسلتنا من بيروت ناهد يوسف ناهد يعني
كان يسالك زميل طاهر عن حاله الهلع يعني
الكثير من اللبنانيين عندما حدثت حدث هذا
الزلزال بساعات الصباح الاولى نزلوا الى
الشارع يعني خوفا منهم من جلس في سيارته
ومنهم من افترش العراء خوفا من اي هزات
ارتداديه هل خف منسوب هذا الهلع الان
يمكن القول راويه انه خفى بناء عن مقارنه
مع ساعات الصباح او عند حصول هذه الهزه
ولكن لا يزال مستمر عند الكثيرين خصوصا
وان عدد كبير من اللبنانيين غادروا
منازلهم خصوصا تلك المنازل او الابنيه
القديمه او ابني العشوائيه التي تنتشر في
عدد كبير من المناطق اللبنانيه وخصوصا تلك
المناطق الفقيره هي معرضه اكثر من غيرها
الى السقوط هناك تصدعات وتشققات حصلت في
بعض منها وعليك كانوا غادروا غادروا هذه
المنازل خوفا من حصول اي هزات ارتداديه
عند حصول هذه الهزه عند الثالثه فجا راينا
عدد كبير من المواطنين باتوا في سياراتهم
خوفا من شدتها خصوصا وانها يعني كان الرعب
غير مسبوق الذي عاشه اللبنانيون لي الامس
وهم شبهوه بالرعب نفسه الذي عايشوه او
شعروا به عند حصول انفجار مرفا بيروت
وعليه كانت مغادره هذه المنازل سريعا
والمبيت في السيارات او المساحات الواسعه
خوفا من اي ارتدادات اخرى رغم الطقس
الماطر والع اليوم ايضا يعني شاهدنا في
منطقه في احدى مناطق بيروت وهي منطقه عدد
كبير من السوريين غادروا منازلهم يعيشون
في احياء قديمه غادروا هذه المنازل والفرش
الارض لساعات بانتظار باصات حضرت واقلتهم
الى اماكن اخرى ان غادروا هذه المنازل
خوفا من حصول اي هزات اخرى وان تسقط لهذا
يعني الرعب لا يزال مستمرا وجاءت هذه
العاصفه ايضا لتزيد يعني من الطين بالله
يعني بسبب البروده الشديده والامطار
الهائله وعليه يعني هناك كانت اجراءات نعم
يعني كنت تتحدثين عن هذه المباني القديمه
يعني منذ فتره توفيت شابه
بالمدرسه نتيجه انهيار السقف عليها قبلها
توفي الطفله ومعها جدتها نتيجه الوجود
العديد المئات بل الالاف من المباني
القديمه في بيروت
والمناطق اللبنانيه هل خروج هؤلاء السكان
كان نتيجه توجيهات
يعني كيف عم تتعامل السلطات اللبنانيه مع
ذلك
يعني هي وجاءك رده فعل اوليه يعني كلنا
حتى حتى انا ايضا يعني خرجت من منزلي عند
حصول هذه الهزه كل اللبنانيين خرجوا
بالمبدا من منازلهم عند حصول هذه ولكن
الابنيه القديمه سكانها بطبيعه الحال احسه
بضروره المغادره وخطوره بقائهم لان
المنازل والابنيه كلها اهتزت على قوه هذا
هذه الهزه صباحا كان كانت الحكومه اجتمعت
بلجنه اداره الكوارث وتم بناء عليها
الاعاز الى جميع المعنيين بمسح هذه
الاضرار ان حصلت اي تصدعات او اي تشققات
كما وزير الداخليه او عزا الى البلديات في
كل لبنان للقيام بالامر عينه ومعاينه اي
خطوره او اي تصدعات ممكن ان تكون نشات عن
هذا
هذه الهزه لم تقم باي اجراء الدوله
اللبنانيه غير ذلك يعني هي فقط اوعزت
للمعنيين بالقيام بذلك انما قرار مغادره
المنازل جاء من الاهالي وذلك خ من سقوط
هذه المباني ان حتى المباني الجديده يعني
المبنيه بشكل منظم اهتزت فكيف الحال
بالمباني القديمه والمباني العشوائيه
وخصوصا في الاحياء السكنيه المقتظه جدا
لذلك كان هذا القرار قرارا مغادره راينا
يعني العديد منهم كانوا باتوا في سياراتهم
خوفا من
تنهار هذه الابنيه ومنهم
من حدوث هزات ارتداديه يمكن ان تبقى لماذا
اطول من ساعات ولذلك تم يعني قرار تعطيل
المدارس والجامعات في اليومين المقبلين في
لبنان كما افتن سابقا ناهد
حداد يعني سبعه ايام وتعطيل للمدارس ايضا
تبقين معنا نهد اتحول الان الى جمعه عكاش
مراسل العربيه من القامشلي جمعه يعني كل
ما استطعت من التجميع ومن معلومات كان
ارقام الحقائق على الارض من المناطق
المنكوبه
مساء الخير لكما ولساده المشاهدين العدد
الاجمالي ل
ضحايا الشمال غرب سوريا ومناطق سيطرت
النظام ارتفع الان من
1383 قتيل الى 1143
مناطق النظام وفي مناطق المعارضه اي في
عموم
في عموم مناطق سوريا
593 وفق احدث احصائيه من ثلاث دقائق
لوزاره الصحه التابعه للنظام 550 وفق
مصادر الدفاع المدني ومشافي عفرين ومشفى
المركزي في ادلب اذا نحن نتحدث عن ارتفاع
الضحايا من 10030 قتيله الى 1143 شخصا
فقدوا حياتهم دعنا نذكر بذلك اذا انت
تتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد ضحايا هذا الزلزال من
القتلى فقط الى
1243 قتيلا
نتحدث عن 593 قتيلا والقمع اعلنته وزاره
الصحه التابعه للنظام السوري اضافه الى
550 قتيلا يعني ممن قضوا في المناطق
الاخرى التي تسيطر عليها المعارضه
المعارضه السوريه طيب الجمعه ماذا عن فرق
الانقاذ ماذا عن ما تحتاجه ما هي
اولوياتها الان
يعني الاولويه تتركز بشكل اساسي
حتى انقاض المنازل خاصه في المناطق التي
شهدت دمارا شبهه شامل وانا اتحدث عن الريف
ادلب الشمالي خاصه بلدات ومدن الاتارب
سرمدا ارمناز حارم في سرمدا حي كامل سقط
يعني الجهود الانقاذ او فرق الانقاذ لم
تصل الى الا سوى لعدد محدد من المنازل في
مدينه جنديرس الكرديه التابعه لمدينه
عفرين تعيش هذه البلده الصغيره وضع
الماساويا كاملا على غرار مدينه الاثارب
التي ارتفع فيها عدد القتلى الى 93 قتيل
في هذه المدينه او في هذه البلده الصغيره
ايضا يعني الاتارب وجنديرس يتقاسمان اعداد
الاعداد الكبرى للقتله وايضا للعوائل
والاشخاص العالقين حتى هذه اللحظات تحت
طبعا عمليات البحث عن ناجين تحت الارقام
تباطات بسبب الليل غياب موارد الكهرباء
وايضا بسبب البرد الشديد وايضا بسبب
الاعياء والتعب الذي لحق بفرق الانقاص
والبحث الذين يعملون منذ الساعه الرابعه
صباحا بتوقيت المحلي لسوريا وانت تتحدث
جمعه وقد حدثت لنا ارقام القتلى
ضحايا هذا زلزال في سوريا اداره الكوارث
التركيه تحدث الارقام فيما يتعلق بعدد
قتلى الزلزال في شمال في تركيا
يرتفع الرقم الى
170 اذا اخر المعلومات ايضا تفيد بان بعثه
الاتحاد الاوروبي الى سوريا تقول ان الدول
الاعضاء تحشد لتقديم المساعدات لسوريا بعد
الزلزال طبعا بما يخص هذه المساعدات
لسوريا اتوجه اليك جمعه من جديد قبل ان
اتابع مع باقي ضيوفنا يعني المساعدات التي
يعني قرر انها ستذهب الى سوريا باي اي
معبر
تذهب كيف ستصل مع العلم بانه سوريا يعني
كلنا نعلم بانها ترزح تحت وطاه العقوبات
الغربيه المفروضه عليها
يعني هذا بالضبط ملف شائك وطريق يعني
المساعدات الانسانيه التي من المفترض ان
تتوجه الى مناطق المعارضه وخاصه الى ادلب
وريف حلبه شمالي والغربي يجب ان تمر عبر
المناطق النظام انه امام يعني تسهيلات او
تسويات مفترض ان يقدمها النظام السوري حتى
تتمكن الامه المنظمات الاغاثيه والامميه
من ادخال المساعدات في حال عن طريق دمشق
او اتت عن طريق ميناء بانياس او او موانع
هي التي تتوجه الى هذه
المناطق هناك شكوك حول قدره يعني الاطراف
المتصارعه في سوريا على ايجاد هدنه
انسانيه لربما لادخال هذه المساعدات
وتوصيلها الى الاف المصابين وعشرات الالاف
الاخرين الذين يعانون من ظروف او تداعيات
الزلزال اضافه الى ظروف الطقس والمناخه
السيئين في هذه
المنطقه حتى الان لا يوجد اي جهه دوليه او
خارجيه تعمل على الاراضي
تبقى معنا جمعه اذا والرقم يرتفع الى
1792 قتيلا في تركيا حتى الان مقابل
1143 قتيلا في سوريا هناك ايضا يعني ارقام
ترتفع بسرعه كبيره للاسف هناك حديث عن
ارقام اكثر من هذا ربما يعني نتاكد من هذه
الارقام اولا قبل ان نذيعها او ناشرها
خاصه في سوريا صحيح ونتابع في تغطيتنا هذه
مع الاستاذ فراس رضوان اوغلو الان اريد ان
اسالك ولو ان قلنا بانه الوقت وقت يعني
تعاضد ومساعده ولكن هل يعني حتى المعارضه
التركيه الان تقف مع الناس قبل ان تقف مع
الحكومه والنظام بشكل عام ولكن هل هناك
نقاط معينه تم التصويب عليها في طريقه
الاداء فيما يتعلق بهذه الامور ان كان قبل
او خلال وحتى هذه الساعات تعامل الحكومه
اقصد مع هذه الكارثه
يعني اذا بدانا بالمعارضه لم يصدر اي بيان
من اي احد يلوم احدا يلوم احد في هذا
السياق لم يصدر لكن قبل عده ساعات كان
هناك اظن صدر
اعلان سرب الى الاعلان بان هناك يعني
وزاره الداخليه كشفت عن 13 موقعا يبثه
اخبارا كاذبه فيها نوع من التحريض هذه
الترجمه
لهذا الخبر ولذلك بعد ذلك خرج السيد عندما
تكلم على التلفاز وقال الرجاء اخذ
المعلومات فقط من الافات حصرا
منظمه الطوارئ في تركيا
لا يوجد اي اظن تعقيب لكن الاداء حتى الان
لا يوجد ايضا
تفصيح تفسير كبير او افصاحات كثيره بسبب
بينما تتحدث الينا بما انه ما فيش تصريحات
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه عم بتقول انه
بلانكن تحدث مع وزير الخارجيه التركي
هذه الكارثه طبعا حول هذا الزلزال وبينما
يعني جهات سوريا تعلن ارتفاع عدد قتل
الزلزال بشمال غرب سوريا في مناطق
المعارضه الى اكثر من 700 نريد ان نسالك
عن الحاجه التركيه الان ما اقصى تحتاجه
تركيا الان في محاولات يعني وما الذي يمكن
ان تقبل به او لا تقبل به ومن اي جهات
يعني حتى اليونان اليوم عرضت المساعده في
هذا الصدد
من حيث انتهيت يعني رغم الخلافه التركي
اليوناني الا ان الطرفين دائما يتساعدان
في كثير من الامور عندما شبت الحرائق في
اليونان التركيه
في تركيا ايضا اليونان ارسلت مساعدات في
هذا السياق لذلك اظن ان في هذه الامور
التعاضد كبير بين الطرفين تركيا لم تعلن
انها لا تريد شيء هي قالتها تريد
المساعدات بشكل كبير اي مساعده تاتي انا
اظن انا الان اهم شيء هي فرق الانقاذ التي
ربما ستاتي وتساعد النقطه الثانيه ما
تمتلك من ادوات التكنولوجيه حديثه النقطه
الثالثه ربما الادويه والمستشفيات
الميدانيه وهذا ما صرحت بهذا الدول ستاتي
منها روسيا والصين وحتى اسرائيل لكن ايضا
عدد الجرحى ايضا قبل قليل تم الزياده الى
11,419 ايضا تم تفريغ ساد في مدينه ملاطيا
تفاديا لبعض
الاحتياط هذا الامر تم الاعلان عن تنبه
الى حصول تسونامي ربما نوعا ما في
الولايات الغربيه عند بحر المتوسط ايضا تم
تخصيص البارجات في
التركيه من اجل ان تكون مستشفى بحري وايضا
للمساعدات وفي النقل طبعا يعني الكثير كل
الكل يعني كل فتره من الزمن يتم اصدار او
تعديلات في البيانات التي تاتي
الوسائل العالم كله يعني يبدو ملتزم الان
بالمساعده وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه تضيف
بانه ملتزمون بعمل بالقيام بكل ما يمكن
فعله على جانبي الحدود التركيه السوريه
بما انه نتحدث عن المساعدات اتوجه الى
ناهد ناهد يعني لبنان رغم يعني امكانياته
متواضعه الدفاع المدني اللبناني نشر فيديو
ارسل فيه فريقا من عناصره الى تركيا
للمساعده هل من معلومات الى اي مناطق جيدا
توجهت
تفاصيل اكثر
نعم يعني منذ حوالي الساعه اقلعت الطائره
من مطار رفيق الحرير الدولي الى اضنه هذا
هذه الطائره ليست فقط تحمل وفد من الدفاع
المدني انما وفدا اللبنانيا شاملا من
الدفاع المدني من الصليب الاحمر من فوج
اطفاء بيروت وايضا من الجيش اللبناني من
فوج الهندسه كلهم ذهبوا في مهمه هي طبعا
للمساعده بكل ما يمكن تقديمه من مساعده
كنا تحدثنا اليهم لمعرفه ما هي اكثر الى
اين وجهتهم ولكن قالوا بان خريطه توجههم
ستحدد في تركيا سيكون هناك من يستقبلهم في
المطار في اضنه وعليه تعطى هذه التوجيهات
سيكون هناك مساعده في عمليه رفع الانقاذ
من قبل هناك ايضا مساعده من الضباط من
الجيش اللبناني من فوج الهندسه الذين ايضا
سيساعدون يعملون على المساعده في عمليه
رفع الانقاذ انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه يعني
كلهم بحسب اختصاصه هي طبعا مساعده محدوده
ولكنها تبقى يعني من بلد لا يملك شيئا هي
مساعده ولفت جميله كانت منهم وهذا هذا هذا
الامر تم باعاز من رئيس الحكومه الى وزير
البيئه ناصر ياسين الذي قام بتشكيل هذا
الوفد ايضا كان اوعى رئيس الحكومه الى
وزير الاشغال علي حميي للتواصل مع سوريا
للغايه نفسها وهو انا كانتواصل مع نظيره
السوري وقال بان كل المساعدات اللوجستيه
تحت تصرفهم في لبنان بكل الطرق التي يمكن
للبنان مساعده سوريا او تركيا في هذه
المحنه تمام شكرا جزيلا لك ناهد يوسف
مراسلات العربيه من بيروت ويبقى معنا
مراسلنا الباقون يعني جمعه كاش وايضا
الصحه في
فراس رضوان اوغلو اتوجه الى جمعه جمعه
يعني فيما يخص
يبدو ان الاتصال مع جمعه قادم انقطع سيد
فراس يعني فيما يخص قطاع الطبي التركي
يعني قرات بالعديد من المواقع والصحف
التركيه بانه هناك كوادر طبيه جاهزه
للذهاب الى المناطق المنكوبه ولكن هناك
العديد من التحديات والعراقيل بنقلهم الى
هناك ما هي تلك
العراقيل وماذا عن الصعوبات وجهزيه القطاع
الطبي في المناطق المتضرره
نعم يعني هناك عده صعوبات اولا الوصول الى
تلك المناطق بعد الطرقات مثل الملاطيا
وعثمانيه فيها مشكله للوصول الى طرقاتها
يتم استخدام الطرقات الالتوائيه والتفافيه
وهذا يعني يؤثر نوعا مافيا وصول المساعدات
المشكله الاخرى اظن هي المستشفيات
الميدانيه على عشر ولايات وبهذه المساحه
الكبيره نحن نتكلم على اكثر من 1500 كيلو
متر امتدادا طوليا من ديار بكر حتى ربما
اسكندرون
لا اظن ان القدره كافيه او الاستيعاب
كافيه لذلك طلب منذ البدايه كان اول ما
طلب ان المساعدات الطبيه وطبعا من ضمنها
ربما المستشفيات الميدانيه هناك مشكله
ثالثه وهي اصول الطاقه هناك بعض المناطق
التي حصل فيها الزلزال او الزلازل الثلاثه
التي اعلن عنها
مقطوعه عنها بعضها الكهرباء وحتى الغاز
وقبل قليل كان يتكلم وزير البيئه ووزير
الطاقه حول اعاده التحكم وتصليح ما يمكن
اصلاحه وقت ممكن لاعاده
مصادر الطاقه الى تلك الناطق اظن ايضا
المشكله الاخرى هو هل الاستعدادات
الدوائيه اي الاعداد الانطوائيه من جرع
وزجاجات وغيرها هل تكفي لهذا المساحات
الكبيره والاعداد يعني انا اظن يعني هذا
ربما تحتاج الى كثير من الجهد لذلك انا
اظن ان حتى الاحوال الجويه يعني كانت قليل
كانوا يتكلمون على ان الطائرات رغم ان
الخطوط الجويه التركيه اعلنت عن فتح خطوط
مستمره دون انقطاع الى الولايات الجنوبيه
الثلاثه ديار بكر واضنه
وانطاكيا ولكن نحن نعلم ان حتى الان لم
يعلن عن فتح المطار في عنتاب وفي انطاكيا
ربما ينتظرون نوع اعاده ترميم المدرج الذي
عطل في انطاكيا وفي عنتاب على الاقل نذكر
بانه فؤاد اقطاي نائب رئيس تركي كان قال
بانه جاره تامين مقر اقامه لمتضررين
الزلزال في كافه المناطق المنكوبه وتم فحص
كافه السدود كما ذكرت انت ايضا استاذ فراس
قبل قليل وجرى التاكد من سلامتها خاصه
بعدما افاد المركز الاوروبي المتوسطي لرصد
الزلازل بوقوع اكثر من 220 هزار ارتداديه
حتى الان في اعقاب الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
الان تؤكد ارتفاع عدد قتلى الزلزال بشمال
غرب سوريا الى اكثر من 700 بمناطق
المعارضه تحديدا والخارجيه الامريكيه تؤكد
التزامها ببذل كل ما في وسعها على جانبي
الحدود التركيه السوريه
شكرا فراس رضوان صحفيه من اسطنبول شكرا
لناهد يوسف مراسله العربيه من بيروت من
جديد
غدرتنا شكرا ايضا لجمعه عكاش مراسل
العربيه من القامشلي ونتابع ما لدينا في
هذه التغطيه المستمره من العربيه حيث
تتعرض تركيا باستمرار لزلازل وهزات ارضيه
حصدت ارواح الاف الضحايا ودمرت المباني
والبنى التحتيه
منذ عام 1500 شهيد التركي نحو 23 زلزالا
مدمرا تجاوزت قوتها سبع درجات وفق تقديرات
علماء الجيولوجيا والمؤرخين زلزال ارزنجان
1939 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله تسعه تسبب
بمصرع 33 الف شخص واصابه نحو 100 الف
زلزال لاتيك
1943 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله سته دمر
75% من ابنيه المنطقه واودى بحياه 2300
شخص
زلزال تشالديران بلغت قوته سبع درجات
فاصله خمسه تسبب بمسرع ثلاثه الاف
وثمانمائه واربعين شخصا
زلزال بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله اثنين
تسبب بمسرع
894 شخصا
زلزالوفان 2011 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله
اثنين ادى الى وفاه اكثر من 70 شخصا
[موسيقى]
مكان نروح فيه
الله اكبر
العالم كلها جايه ربحوا عم تعاونها دعقم
دعكم احنا ما لنا حاجه مالنا غير رب
العالمين
[تصفيق]
البيت الابيض يقول قبل قليل ان بيضا
سيتحدث مع رجب طيب اردوغان قريبا حول
الزلزال اضافه الى اخبار عاجله عن وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه التي لا تزال تصرح
بلنكن قال بوضوح لنظيره تشاويش اوغلو
مستعدون لتلبيه اي حاجه من حاجات التركيه
فقط ارفعوا سماعه الهاتف
ودعونا نعلم بذلك تقول وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه بانه القنصليه الامريكيه في
اضنه في جنوب تركيا ستكون قادره على
استضافه يعني فرق الانقاذ والمرصد السوري
باخر تحديثاته حول ارتفاع حصيله قتل
الزلزال بسوريا ارتفع الى
قتيلا نتابع عربه الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو بوتيريش عن تعازيه لاسر
ضحايا الزلزال المدمر الذي شهدته اراضي
تركيا وسوريا
مؤكدا ان على الامم المتحده ان تدعوا
لمساعده المتضرر ان تدعو لمساعده
المتضررين
اود ان انقل حزني من الزلازل المدمره التي
ضربت تركيا وسوريا كما اقدم احر التعازي
لاسر الضحايا والامم المتحده تدعو للعمل
لمساعده المتضررين من الكارثه فهم في امس
الحاجه الى المساعدات الانسانيه
اوضح وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انا واشنطن
تقيم خيارات الاستجابه الشامله للزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا قبل ان نقرا
هذه الاخبار العاجله الان طبعا صحيح واكد
بلنكن في بيان ان بلاده ستبذل كل ما في
وسعها لمساعده المتضررين خلال الفتره
المقبله مضيفا انا واشنطن مع انقره
وشركائها في المجال الانساني لتحديد ما
تحتاجه المنطقه في الايام المقبله يمكن
اشار الى ان جهود الاستجابه الاوليه في
تركيا جاريه بالفعل مؤكدا ان المنظومات او
المنظمات الانسانيه المدعومه من واشنطن في
سوريا تستجيب لاثار الزلازل في جميع انحاء
البلاد
وخبر اخر عن الخارجيه الامريكيه محور
سؤالك قبل قليل لضيوفنا المعابر الانسانيه
الى سوريا تقول الخارجيه الامريكيه يجب ان
تظل مفتوحه امام حركه المنظمات الاهليه
عبر الحدود كانت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
اكدت ان فرنسا سترسل 17 عنصرا من فرق
الانقاذ اضافه الى 65 عنصرا من فرق
الاطفاء الى تركيا بالاضافه الى افراد من
مركز الازمات والدعم وذلك استجابه لطلب
الدعم الدولي الذي قدمته تركيا
هذا وعبر المستشار الالماني عن حزنه جراء
الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه مشيرا الى ان
بلاده تنسق مع الحكومه التركيه لتقديم
المساعدات اللازمه
اولا اود ان اقول لاهالي ضحايا هذه
الكارثه الرهيبه اننا متضامنون معكم وانه
امر محزن للغايه ولذلك قدمنا المساعده بكل
الامكانيات المتوفره لدينا ونحن ننسق الان
مع الحكومه التركيه لتقديم المساعده
يؤكد استعداد منظمه الامم المتحده لدعم
جهود الاستجابه الطارئه بعيدا وجهت فريقي
للتنسيق مع تركيا وتوفير المساعدات
اللازمه
[موسيقى]
مستعدون للمساعده في القضاء على تدعيه
الكارثه
ماكرون فرنسا مستعده لتوفير مساعده عاجله
للسكان في تركيا وسوريا اسرائيل تعرض
ارسال فرق بحث وانقاذ وفرق طبيه الى تركيا
وسوريا
المانيا تعهدت بتقديم مساعدات شامله
لضحايا الزلزال عبر كل الوسائل المتاحه
ايطاليا بدات بالفعل في تجهيز فرق الانقاذ
التي ستسافر الى تركيا
بكين تعلن استعدادها لتقديم مساعدات
انسانيه عاجله الى تركيا وسوريا
قبل الذهاب طاهر الى مقاله واعلام النظام
السوري المرصد السوري حصيل الضحايا
الزلزال مرشحه للارتفاع في هذا الخبر
العاجل بسبب وجود عائله باكملها تحت
الانقاض وانه معظم الاضرار جراء الزلزال
تتركز في الشمال غرب سوريا المجلس
الاوروبي نذكر بانه كان قرر تفعيل اليه
الاستجابه للازمات لتنسيق الدعم لمواجهه
اثار الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا
نقل اعلام النظام السوري عن مصدر رسمي
تشديده على ان دمشق لن تطلب اي مساعده من
اسرائيل وجاء هذا النفي بعد ان قال رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو انه
اصدر تعليمات بتقديم العون للمتضررين من
الزلزال في سوريا بعد تلقي طلب بهذا
الخصوص وكان نتنياهو اوضح ايضا ان وجهها
بارسال فرق بحث وانقاذ وفرق طبيه الى
تركيا بناء على طلب من حكومه انقره
ينضم الينا شبكه مراسلينا من باريس حسين
قنيبر من لندن مصطفى زار وايضا من واشنطن
ناديه البلبيسي اهلا بكم جميعا ابدا معك
ناديه يعني بايدن اعلن عن مساعدات عاجله
لتركيا كان يتحدث منذ قليل عن انه
الخارجيه الامريكيه يعني مستعده لان تساعد
باي شيء تطلبه انقره ماذا في التفاصيل
في الواقع هناك حاله استنفار في كل
الوكالات الامريكيه والوزارات يعني قبل
قليل سمعنا من جون كاربي في البيت الابيض
يقول بانه بالاضافه الى ما ذكرتيه قبل
قليل ان البيت الابيض سيرسل فريقين بحث
وانقاذ مكونين من 79 عنصر الى تركيا وطبعا
الرئيس بايدن سيتصل مع الرئيس اردوغان في
الساعات القادمه عدا عن ذلك وزاره الدفاع
البينتاجون قالت بانها مستعده لتقديم كل
العون
للحليف في حل شمال الاطلسي وطبعا تركيا
بالتحديد تقصد هنا بالنسبه لسوريا انا
سالت جون كاربي في مكالمه هاتفيه قبل قليل
علما طبعا كما تعرفين بانه الولايات
المتحده لا يوجد لديها علاقات دبلوماسيه
مع نظام السوري ولا يوجد هناك ايضا اي
وجود امريكي يعني بهذا المعنى عدا عن
المنظمات الانسانيه وايضا هناك مقاطعه ضد
النظام كيف يمكن للاداره ان تقدم عون
للمتضررين في داخل سوريا فجونكر باكد لنا
للعربيه بانه الولايات المتحده ستعمل مع
كل المنظمات الانسانيه الموجوده في داخل
سوريا وستعمل مع الامم المتحده لتوفير كل
الدعم المطلوب لكن اعتقد بانه التركيز
سيكون على تركيا لانه لسهوله ارسال الفرق
الطبيه الامريكيه الولايات المتحده لديها
خبره ايضا في التعامل مع الزلازل وخصوصا
في ولايه كاليفورنيا وبالتالي هي لديها كل
الاجهزه الحديثه التي يمكن ان تكشف عن
وجود للاشخاص الموجودين تحت الانقاض لذا
اعتقد بانه بالفعل هناك يعني دعم كبير جدا
على كل المستويات وليس فقط على المستوى
الحكومي لكن ايضا على مستوى وكاله التنميه
الامريكيه التي لديها وجود طبعا على
الحدود التركيه السوريه وهناك دعوه كما
ذكرت قبل قليل من وزاره الخارجيه لابقاء
كل المعابر مع سوريا بالتحديد ان تكون
مفتوحه وخصوصا بان تركيا كانت قد هددت في
السابق باغلاق هذه المعابر المشتركه على
الحدود السوريه التركيه لكن الولايات
المتحده تراقب ما يحدث وكما ذكرتي يا
مستعده لتوفير كل الدعم المتوفر لديها
وعلى اتصال على فكره هناك اتصال مباشر
اتصال مباشر بين وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
والتركي وايضا بين المسؤولين في وزاره
الدفاع والبيت الابيض مجلس الامن القومي
والمسؤولين الاتراك تبقينا معنا ناديه
شكرا على كل هذه المعلومات الى حسين ق
الان مراسل العربيه من باريس وطبيعه
الاستجابه الفرنسيه حسين لو سمحت
ناديه من استنفار للوزارات والوكالات في
الولايات المتحده يحدث امر مشابه له في
فرنسا حيث تسير المساعدات الفرنسيه على
اربعه مسارات وزاره الخارجيه وزاره
الداخليه بلديه باريس وتحالف المنظمات
الانسانيه الفرنسيه اولا وزاره الخارجيه
اعلنت انه بعض اتصال بين الوزيره كاترين
كولونا ونظيرها التركي تقرر ان تبدا فرنسا
عمليه واسعه النطاق للحمايه المدنيه او
الدفاع المدني كما سميت من ضمن هذه
العمليه سيتوجه خلال ساعات الى تركيا 71
عنصرا من فرق الانقاذ وخمسه وستون عنصرا
من فرق الاطفاء وعناصر من مركز الازمات
والدعم التابع لوزاره الخارجيه وكذلك
سيتوجه افراد في مفرزتين تابعتين لوزاره
الداخليه متخصصتين
في البحث تحت الانقاض هذا على مستوى
الوزارتين الخارجيه والداخليه ايضا عمده
باريس
قالت انه وليساعده المنكوبين في تركيا
وسوريا سيصار الى تركيز بل الى تحريك
صندوق المساعدات العاجله لمساعده
المنكوبين الاهم من ذلك طاهر وراويه ان
تحالفا من سته منظمات انسانيه فرنسيه من
بينها اطباء بلا حدود وكير فراس اعلنت ان
فرقها على الارض تنشط لتقديم الدعم النفسي
والاسعافات الاوليه وتوفير المواد
الغذائيه الضروريه والعنايه الطبيه
الضروريه
لاشخاص موجودين في مدن تركيا يبلغ عدد
سكانها 12 مليون شخص هذه المدن هي خصوصا
غازي عنتاب ديار بكر اديمان هاتاي كلس
ملااتيا وكذلك ديار بكر في هذه المدن هناك
مخاطر في تركيا من ارتفاع عدد الضحايا
بشكل كبير ليس فقط لان عددا كبيرا من
الضحايا ما زال موجودا تحت الانقاض بل لان
الالاف مشردين من دون ماوى من دون غذاء
ومن دون عنايه طبيه كما قالت هذه المنظمات
الانسانيه الفرنسيه التي وجهت نداء عاجلا
لتقديم مساعدات لهؤلاء المنكوبين حسين الى
مصطفى زارو من لندن ماذا عن المساعدات
البريطانيه يعني اكثر من 45 دوله من ضمنها
بريطانيا عرض التقديم مساعدات عاجله
انسانيه لتركيا فماذا عن تركيا وماذا عن
الذي سيقدم لسوريا ان كان هناك
نيه لذلك
حقيقه وزاره الخارجيه اصدرت بيانا اكدت
فيه ان سته وسبعين متخصصا في البحث
والانقاذ من المملكه المتحده واربعه كلاب
بحث ومعدات انقاذ توجه توجهوا الى غازي
عنتاب ومن ثم الى المناطق الاكثر تضررا
لمساعده في انقاذ اكبر عدد من الارواح في
عقاب هذا الزلزال المدمر كما تجري ايضا
الحكومه البريطانيه تنسيقا مع
الامم المتحده بشان الدعم الانساني الطارئ
لمتضررين في سوريا منظمه الخوذ البيضاء
المموله من قبل المملكه المتحده يعني حشدت
جميع مواردها
لبدء عمليه الانقاذ للمتضررين في هذا
الزلزال في المناطق السوريه ووزير
الخارجيه جيمس كليفري قال بان بريطانيا
ستزيد من دعمها المنظمه بالاضافه ان
بريطانيا مستعده لتقديم المزيد من
المساعدات حسب الحاجه وفق ما قاله
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كلي ايضا من
ضمن هذا الدعم الذي قدمته بريطانيا الى
تركيا وهو فريق فريق طبي لتقييم الوضع على
الارض الى جانب ان السفاره البريطانيه في
انقره تواصل
اتصالاتها مع السلطات التركيه لفهم من
افضل ما تحتاجه تركيا في هذه الحاله خصوصا
وان هناك دعم كبير من قبل
جميع دول العالم في في هذا الزلزال المروع
ولكن بريطانيا على هبه الاستعداد لتقديم
المزيد منها احنا ما ما قاله وزير
الخارجيه قبل قبل قليل بان حتى هذه اللحظه
ليس هناك اي ضحايا او او اصابات في صفوف
البريطانيين لكن بال اقل من المبكر جزم
بان ليست هناك اي اصابات او ضحايا في هذا
الوقت المبكر ولكن هناك
خطان ساخنا واحد في تركيا
للاتصال لمن يريد يعني الدعم والحاجه الى
ربما
المجيء الى بريطانيا بالاضافه الى خط اخر
في المملكه المتحده يجب الاتصال على كل من
لديه قلق بشان اقارب واصدقاء في تركيا يجب
ان يتواصلوا مع مكتب وزاره الخارجي
وبالتالي هناك تواصل دائم مع
الجهات التركيه وايضا مع المنظمات الدوليه
بخصوص هذه المساعده التي يتم تقديمها سواء
لتركيا او لسوريا
مصطفى زارو تبقى معنا شكرا على كل هذه
المعلومات واعود هنا الى ناديه
بالبيسي من واشنطن والحديث كان قبل قليل
في الاخبار العاجله عن انه بايدن سيتحدث
قريبا وفقا للبيت الابيض الى
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان لابداء كل
ما يمكن المساعده فيه امريكيا
هل يصنف الاعلام الامريكي في تغطياته ما
هو سياسي في هذا الموضوع وما هو انساني
لا اعتقد بانه حجم الضرر الذي احدثه هذا
الزلزال ربما
يغطى فيه الجانب الانساني اكثر من الجانب
السياسي هناك خلافات بين واشنطن وانقره
معروفه لكن بالنسبه للمساعده الامريكيه
اصلا البيت الابيض والرئيس بايدن عندما
اصدر البيان صباح اليوم قال فيه في
البدايه قبل ان يعرض المساعدات قلب انه
يعرب عن اسفه الشديد هو والسيده الاولى
لما حدث وقدم التعازل الرئيس اردوغان ولا
الشعب التركي وبالتالي اعتقد بانه التركيز
الان هو على الجانب الانساني على هذا
الضرر الذي حدث في تركيا وفي سوريا من كل
جوانبي سواء كانت اضرار انسانيه طبعا
تتعلق بعدد القتلى والجرحى والمشردين
والمباني
وكل ما يعني يتطلب ايضا ربما نقطه لم يوجد
فيها وهي لا اعرف اذا كان هناك معلومات
هناك قاعده انجليك الموجوده في جنوب تركيا
اعرف اذا كانت ضمن المحيط الجغرافي
للزلزال او لا لكن هي قاعده مهمه تستخدمها
الولايات المتحده في كل عمليات العسكريه
لكن هي تركز بالدرجه الاولى طائر على ان
تركيا هي عضو مهم في حلف شمال الاطلسي
وهذا ما ذكره بالتحديد بيان البيت الابيض
لكن كما ذكرت التركيز الان بالنسبه لاداره
الرئيس بايدن وتوفير كل المعونات
الانسانيه بكل المحتاجين وباسرع وقت ممكن
شكرا جزيلا لك نادي البلبيسي من واشنطن من
لندن ايضا مصطفى زارو ومن باريس حسين
قنيبر شكرا
شكرا لكم جميعا
قائمه ببعض اشد الزلازل فتكا على الصعيد
العالميه في العقدين المنصرمين
ابرز الزلازل المميته حول العالم في
الرابع عشر من اغسطس عام 2021
زلزال بقوه 7.2 درجه ومقتل ما يزيد عن
2200 شخص
في السادس عشر من ابريل عام 2016
الاكوادور زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه ومقتل 650
شخصا
في الخامس والعشرين من ابريل عام 2015
نيبال زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه وتسبب بمقتل
تسعه الاف شخص
الحادي عشر من مارس عام 2011
اليابان زلزال مدمر بقوه تسع درجات خلف
عشرين الفا بين قتيل ومفقود السادس
والعشرون من ديسمبر عام 2003 ايران زلزال
بقوه 6.6 درجه اسفر عن مقتل 31 الف شخص
ينضم الينا من عمان الان غسان سويدان رئيس
مركز رصد الزلازل الاردني اهلا بك معنا
استاذ غسان في العربيه 360 في هذه التغطيه
المستمره من العربيه
لزلزال تركيا وسوريا هل الخطر لا يزال
قائما
نعم يا سيدي لا زالت الامور غير مستقره
وهنالك زلازل ارتداديه في نفس المنطقه
وكما نعلم انه هاي الزلازل الارتداديه قد
تكون اكثر شده بالرغم من اقل قوه من
الزلزال الرئيسي الا انها تساعد في عمليات
الهدم للمباني التي خلقت من جراء الزلزال
الكبير بس ممكن يكون في زلازل اخرى ايضا
مش هزات اخرى يعني مش هزات ارتداديه فقط
لانه في يعني واحد منهم على الاقل حسب على
انه زلزال اخر حصل بعد منه وليس هزار
ارتداديه نعم صحيح يا سيدي وهذا ما كنا
يعني لم نتوقعه حيث كان الزلزال الاول
اللي هو الساعه الرابعه وسبعه عشر دقيقه
بتوقيت تركيا
فجرا لحقه زلزال قوه سته سبعه بالعشره بعد
عشر دقائق وبلشت الامور تنزل وتهدى
ثلاث درجات اربع درجات خمس درجات الى غايه
الساعه الواحده و25
تفاجانا بحدود زلزال كبير جدا كانت قوته
لا تقل عن قوه عن الزلزال الكبير اللي هو
حصل الفجر اللي كانت قوه سبعه وسته
بالعشره سبعه وسبعه بالعشره للاسف انه
يعني هذا كان شيء غير متوقع ولكن سبحان
الله هذا ما حصل طيب سيد غسان يعني كان
اللافت بهذا الزلزال الكبير هو مدته يعني
اكثر من اربعين ثانيه وهي مده طويله جدا
وتحدث فيها اضرار كبيره
حدثنا عن يعني توقعاتك بالساعات القادمه
يعني عندما يقال بانه
تتنشط الحركه الزلزاليه بمناطق معينه تبقى
ناشطه لايام مثلا ام ماذا
صدقا لا يمكن لاحد ان يتنبا ماذا سيحصل
ولكن نتمنى ان لا يزيد يعني ان لا يبدا
الزلزال بالانخماد وتقل الطاقه
الكامله داخل هذا الزلزال وانتقل الهزات
الارتداديه ولكن لا احد يستطيع ان يقول
لنا كم هي المده وكم عدد الزلازل واذا
كانت
مؤشرات ربما
ليس هناك مؤشرات نحن نقوم برصد كل الزلازل
الموجوده في المنطقه وان شاء الله انه
الامور تكون بخير ما في عوامل معززه
للاسف سيدي ما في يعني اي شيء ممكن يعني
نعتمد عليه يعني هاي حركه فجائيه في صفائح
الكره الارضيه
طاقه كامله تفجرت هذه
الطاقه جراء الضغوطات الهائله على الكتل
الارضيه
وبدقه هذه الطاقه يعني في الاحتياطات في
بناء تحتيه في طبيعه البناء في يعني
عفوا ممكن تساله يكون هل تاثير هذه
الزلازل على البنى التحتيه طبعا هو بيعتمد
الدمار على البعد المنطقه عن الزلزال
نوعيه بناء ونوعيه التربه اذا كانت التربه
رمليه تختلف عن الصخريه تختلف عن الرمليه
والى اخره سيد غسان انت تتابع تعاطي
السلطات التركيه والسلطات يعني لا اريد ان
اقول السلطات السوريه لانه المناطق منقسمه
بين تابعه للنظام وتابعه للمعارضه السوريه
ولكن النواقص بالخطط المتبعه على الارض
فرق الانقاذ التعامل مع هكذا زلزال يعني
نحن لا نتعامل مع بنايه وقعت نحن نتعامل
مع الالاف من الابنيه التي انهارت مع اناس
بحاجه للانقاذ صحيح صحيح ستي ما حصل هو
دمار شامل دمار كبير جدا غير متوقع وتوقع
انه يفوق استعدادات اي بلد في العالم مهما
كان متطور يعني احنا بنعتبر تركيا دوله
متطوره جدا بخصوص التعامل مع الزلازل ولكن
ما حصل من دمار
حاله الطقس الموجوده حاليا فهذا صعب جدا
انه يتعاملوازيه يعني حتى لو كانت دوله
متقدمه جدا بس هي على خط صدع اساسي وخطير
جدا ومعرض للزلازل دائما
شايفين البنيه التحتيه والبنيات مش جاهزه
جدا يعني بل قديمه وفي بعضها متاكد
[موسيقى]
المناطق المنكوبه بحيث انه يعني نعطي مجال
للقوى لانقاذ خاصه انه هم يمتلكون واذا
احنا يعني كنا في بيتنا ومتوقعين زلزال
يعني نحاول نحتمي وناخذ الحمايه الكافي
لانفسنا ان شاء الله عموما في الكثير على
مواقع التواصل من هذه النصائح المهمه التي
ذكرتها بها استاذ غسان السويدان رئيس مركز
رصد الزلازل الاردني من عمان تحياتنا اليك
شكرا
يا رب
الله
[موسيقى]
هكذا نختم هذه الساعه فقط من التغطيه
ولكنها مستمره
للحزال الذي وصفته احدى الناجيات اليوم
بانه كان وكان العالم انتهى بالنسبه اليهم
على الاقل